they've overcome huge obstacles and
distances to reach Tunisia but the
perilous journey is far from over for
these sub-Saharan migrants they're
camping out in front of this U.N Refugee
agency building in the Tunisian Capital
we're not here to create problems we're
only on route to Europe we're not here
to stay or harm the locals but even
amongst us there are harmful people who
are harassing us situation in facts is
very bad
many are scared afraid to even wander
the streets attacks on migrants have
increased in recent months the life we
hate and soon is is hard hard for the
people black you understand yes
um the people
attack other people
the color skin you know is important in
fact
much
air time attack the people back I don't
know why
last week tunisia's second largest city
svaxx saw intense clashes between
residents and migrants
a brawl on Monday saw a Tunisian man
stabbed to death
in response Tunisian authorities
forcibly deported hundreds of migrants
from the city to the Tunisian Libyan
border Human Rights Watch accused
Tunisia of violating international law
by Collective expulsions of black
migrants
some tunisians agree Collective
expulsions are definitely a violation of
international law and basic principle of
Justice you cannot collectively judge
the people
um for without giving them proper rights
the Tunisian Libyan border has been
described as no man's land some have
been here for a week but every day more
black migrants are being dumped here by
Tunisian authorities they are enduring
scorching heat and say they have no food
or water more than 1200 migrants
including women and children are
stranded here
some are injured and need medical
assistance
but no help has come
expelled from Tunisia barred from Libya
stuck between the two the situation for
the hundreds of migrants near the Libyan
border is desperate there are fears that
if humanitarian assistance doesn't reach
them soon their plight will only grow
Grimmer malotrena Al Jazeera swara